on commence donc par ce rapport de human
rights watch qui dénonce des exactions
commises par l'armée malienne mais pas
seulement le rapport épingle également
les attaques djihadistes à répétition
qui cible à la fois les femmes à et les
populations bénédicte jeannerod
directrice france de l'eau angie était
avec nous tout à l'heure elle est
revenue sur le contenu de ce rapport
écoutez
nous avons mené des entretiens avec des
dizaines de témoins et d'autres
personnes et nous avons documenté huit
incidents dans le centre et dans le sud
ouest du mali qui implique des groupes
armés islamistes et l'armée malienne et
ses différents événements que nous avons
documenté se sont soldées par le meurtre
de 107 personnes des civils y compris
des suspects est donc parmi eux des
commerçants des chefs de village des
chefs religieux et des enfants et
l'appui par des victimes ont présumément
était sommairement exécutés alors pour
ce qui est des groupes armés islamistes
ils sont impliqués dans 36 meurtre sur
les 107 depuis le mois de décembre et
elles ont notamment tué je signale cette
cet incident là que nous avons documenté
tué 32 personnes dont au moins six
enfants lors d'une embuscade qui a été
tendue à des commerçants qui circulait
en bus début décembre alors qu'il se
rendait dans un marché à bandiagara et
beaucoup de ces personnes ont été brûlés
vifs un des témoins qui nous avons
interviewé par lé d'un d'un véritable
d'un véritable carnage et du côté de
l'armée donc qui est impliqué dans 71
meurtres la plupart lors d'opérations
antiterroristes et elle s'est livrée à
des attaques manifestement aux
représailles à des morts à des morts
après la mort de deux soldats et elle a
tué de nombreuses personnes dans des
villages mais aussi début mars au moins
trente cinq suspects qui étaient détenus
dans le camp militaire de dia ben ali et
dont les suspects tués dans les corps
ont été dans les corps calcinés ont été
retrouvés à proximité à une dizaine de
kilomètres de 10 à bâle il s'agit là de
la de la pire allégations contre l'armée
que nous avons deux dû monter depuis
depuis 2012 alors dans votre rapport
vous parlez également d'hommes blancs
qui ne parle pas français qui seraient
aussi responsables d'exactions
alors effectivement dans certains
témoins qui nous avons que nous avons
interviewés ont décrit la présence de
soldats blancs qui ne parlait pas qu'ils
parlaient une langue en fait qu'il ne
comprenait pas dans plusieurs opérations
de l'armée et des opérations au cours
desquelles des exactions ont été ont été
commises notamment d'ailleurs celle que
j'évoquais juste avant qui a concerné
l'exécution sommaire de trente cinq
suspects détenus au camp de deux diabaly
donc donc début mars et par suppositions
en fait comme barkan
et à kouba et ni la minus mains ne sont
opérationnels dans cette zone on peut
penser qu'il s'agisse de russes engagés
auprès du groupe auprès du groupe wagner
donc je m'adresse soit je ne prends pas
position sur l'utilisation de troupes
comme comme wagner mais en revanche on
surveille une documentons de manière
très approfondie leurs comportements et
c'est ce que nous allons continuer à
faire et ça fera probablement l'objet
d'un prochain rapport de la part des
human rights watch dans la prochainement
dans les prochains jours dans les
prochaines semaines alors aujourd'hui
vous demander aux autorités de
transition de faciliter la conduite des
enquêtes indépendantes
oui alors en fait comme toujours ce que
nous documentons ça produit des
allégations qui finalement ne sont que
des allégations qui demande à être
investigués et c'est pour ça que nous
demandons au gouvernement de mener lui
mène des enquêtes crédibles sur les
différents incidents et les différentes
allégations qui sont documentés dans
notre dans notre rapport est également
de favoriser ou de faciliter des
enquêtes indépendantes qui sont menées
par la section droits de l'homme de la
minus m'a également par la commission
nationale des droits de l'homme c'est
très important qu'elle qu'elle le fasse
on se on salue d'ailleurs le fait que le
gouvernement ait annoncé déjà
l'ouverture d' enquête sur trois des
incidents que nous documentons dans
notre dans notre rapport et je dirais
que là que la question des enquêtes
c'est non seulement une question
essentielle pour rendre justice aux
victimes et à leurs familles et puis
aussi pour sanctionner les personnes qui
subissent qui pendant qu'ils perpètrent
qui perpètrent 1 qui commettent de tels
de telles exactions mais c'est aussi une
question je dirais de
de crédibilité vis-à-vis des populations
on sait que la défiance de la part d'un
certain nombre de communautés à l'égard
des autorités est un terreau ou un
terrain très favorable pour le
recrutement des groupes armés
djihadistes donc le fait que les
autorités mènent des enquêtes sérieuses
traîne des mesures ou des sanctions
contre les personnes qui se prête à de
telles exactions c'est aussi une
question de rétablir la confiance et de
crédibilité vis-à-vis de deux
communautés qui ont un grand sentiment
de défiance